gleich stichverletzungen unterm kinn
2007 einen kopfschuss erlitten von
hinten und hier oben den oberschenkel
mit den sehen darunter abgetrennt es
wird unten schon viel geld damit gemacht
häufig haben ein büro hat sich damals
die schießerei ereignet ich habe
grundsätzlich eine neun millimeter dabei
gehabt
da hat es nicht damals die schießerei
ereignet v leute sind für uns in diesem
extrem wichtig ich habe sachen erlebt im
rotlicht-milieu es ist natürlich ein
sehr sehr abgeschlossener bereich
etablissements clubs sowie
zimmervermietung die hells angels immer
mehr als bei anderen mischten damit
jetzt unwahrscheinlich viel geld damit
gemacht so großes elend häufig reden wir
ja auch über sex und ausnutzung von
osteuropäischen frauen die leute
zugreifen leider gottes bei männern wie
mir immer zu drastischen massnahmen
braucht es wirklich so weit gehen dass
man mir tatsächlich keller schickte mir
ging es einfach darum den fuß in die
szene zu kriegen auf einer anderen
[Musik]
vor 20 jahren ging jan sander das letzte
mal durch hamburgs rotlichtviertel
hier war er türsteher alle kannten ihn
als und er mit nur wenig später machte
er sich in der szene als zuhälter einen
namen
was damals keiner ahnte der immer braun
gebrannte miami jenny führte ein
gefährliches doppelleben
er war für das landeskriminalamt in
hamburg und sammelte heimlich für die
polizei wichtige information im kiez
milieu
jetzt packte über seine vergangenheit
aus es war damals bekannt in hamburg das
durch ec und scheckkarten betrug sehr
viel gelder eingenommen werden es war
bekannt dass grundsätzlich auch 18 19
und 20 jährige zur prostitution nicht
unbedingt gezwungen werden aber
überredet werden zur meiner zeit und das
ist bis heute auch so geblieben war die
maric bande sehr aktiv mit eigenen
hinter bismarck clubs sowie
zimmervermietung die hells angels und
auch albaner aber auch die türsteher
szene war damals schon hart umkämpft
also immer mehr als bei anderen mischten
damit und gleichzeitig auch iraner und
natürlich die türken
anfang 2000 immer wieder brechen revier
kriege zwischen den zuhälter banden aus
schlägereien messerangriffe sogar
schüsse fallen
der frieden auf dem kiez wird blutig
erkämpft es geht hauptsächlich um frauen
und das geschäft welche für wen
anschafft und um zig millionen euro die
polizei verstärkt zunehmend ihre präsenz
auf der reeperbahn
regelmäßig finden den bordellen und
laufhäuser razzien statt ermittelt wird
gegen die betreiber wegen
steuerhinterziehung menschenhandel und
sexueller ausbeutung was mein
schwerpunkt war in zusammenarbeit mit
den behörden
da lag mein fokus grundsätzlich mal auf
gewaltdelikte gegen frauen auf schwere
gewalttaten zum nachteil von frauen ich
habe sachen erlebt im rotlicht- und da
muss man leider gottes sagen meistens
zugang durch durch ausländer
das ist nun mal so gerade die die
zuhälter vom balkan oder auch aus der
türkei die nehmen da überhaupt keine
rücksicht für die zählt einfach nur der
finanzielle profil
es gab situationen in denen ich leider
gottes wegschauen musste weil ich dann
aufgeflogen wäre
und das sind natürlich so sachen die
nimmst du auch mit nach hause
jenny tauscht sich regelmäßig mit den
lka beamten aus die orte dafür sind
beliebig und in der öffentlichkeit sie
dürfen nicht auffallen deshalb treffen
sich die männer häufig im restaurant
eines kaufhauses bei kaffee und kuchen
ich kann mich da an eine situation
erinnern da habe ich von einer
informantin den hinweis bekommen dass
wohl in einem billighotel eine
minderjährige anschaffen soll zu unserem
erstaunen war diese angeblich
minderjährige im besitz eines
personalausweises der sie als 24 jährige
aus wie es doch danach stellte sich
heraus dass die überprüfte person im
besitz eines gefälschten ausweises war
nicht nur minderjährig sei sondern
gerade mal 13 jahre alt ist
regelmäßig setzt die polizei hamburg im
bereich organisierte kriminalität kurz
oka sogenannte vertrauensleute 1
sie sind ein wichtiges mittel zur
aufklärung schwerer straftaten bauleute
sind für uns in diesem extrem wichtig es
ist natürlich ein sehr abgeschlossener
bereich es wird unwahrscheinlich viel
geld damit gemacht so großes elend
häufig reden wir ja auch über sex und
ausnutzung von osteuropäischen frauen
und deswegen haben wir natürlich ein
hohes maß an interesse dort tätig zu
werden
und das gelingt uns häufig jeden nur
über menschen die in diesem milieu
unterwegs sind dafür brauchen wir dieses
instrument der frau leute
ich bin mit meiner internatszeit
natürlich unter vielen auch schwer
erziehbar ein junge gewesen die gewalt
eingesetzt haben um schwächere zu
unterdrücken und da war es eigentlich
pflicht dass man sich im späteren alter
dann auch schützt indem man sich
körperlich fit hält
jenny wird 1977 als jan sander nordrhein
westfälischen ratingen geboren seine
mutter ist deutsche sein vater syrer die
eltern trennen sich als ja noch ein
beben lässt seine mutter heiratet wenig
später einen wohlhabenden geschäftsmann
der zwei kinder mit in die ehe bringt
zwischen den stief geschwistern gibt es
regelmäßig ärger jan willich der
schwächere sein
er beginnt mit bodybuilding und
kampfsport ich wollte immer wo groß
seien bereit sein maskulin sein
ich habe dicke arme dicke bei eine
breite schultern große muss muskeln
bewundert ich bin in der ära des anderen
schwarzenegger groß geworden in den
80ern 90ern und habe mich immer an
diesen leuten orientiert
[Musik]
die leute greifen leider gottes bei
männern wie mir immer zu drastischen
maßnahmen und das geht zum teil an aber
auch böse für mich aus ich habe unter
anderem eine stichverletzung am oberarm
ich habe zwei stichverletzungen und im
halsbereich das mit der kontrahent auf
den rücken gesprungen
ich habe 2007 einen kopfschuss erlitten
von hinten beigefügt durch marcel m in
hamburg ich habe zwei schreckschüsse im
hinteren oberschenkelbereich gehabt ich
hatte unter anderem an einer
auseinandersetzung da ist der kontrahent
auf mich zu mit einem deko schwert mich
hier an der ware erwischt und hier oben
den oberschenkel mit den sehen darunter
abgetrennt mit über 20 stichen genäht
und dass solche verletzungen lassen sich
leider gottes nicht vermeiden und auch
so was unangenehm ist wie eine
abgebrochene flasche nicht da kam ihr
kontrahent der lag schon auf dem boden
ich mit dem rücken zu ihm und da hat er
dann mehr noch eine abgebrochene
bierflasche sehr unschön den den globus
maximus gerammt was auch nicht genäht
werden konnte da die glassplitter raus
wachsen müssen weil sie sich für uns ja
gut das gehört mit dazu und man kann es
auch nicht kontrollieren
es war für mich immer ein muss erst in
der security branche als türsteher dann
danach tätigkeit für die behörden in den
verschiedenen subkulturen in der nicht
eingesetzt worden
ein bereich wo k und dann gerade auch
das zuhälter mühe dabei dieser
körperkult auch immer ein thema
jenny ist in der hamburger szene
angesehen
er wird respektiert viele vertrauen doch
der 30-jährige wird getrieben von seinem
eigenen ehrgeiz
er möchte noch einflussreicher werden
noch tiefer in die schöne eintauchen um
noch mehr geld zu verdienen und noch
mehr informationen für die behörden
zusammen
denn neben der prostitution haben sich
im hamburger rotlichtmilieu mittlerweile
neue geschäftszweige gebildet der
drogen- und waffenhandel floriert und
wirft millionen ab
jenni trifft eine wichtige entscheidung
er eröffnet das tropicana und ist ab
sofort chef seines eigenen fkk clubs
das problem war damals dass dafür keine
mittel freigegeben worden sind eine
behörde wird niemals ein paar der
betrieb finanz hier mit steuergeldern
und da ich aber mittlerweile ganz gut in
der szene zurecht kam und auch über die
eine oder andere kontakte zu frauen
verfügte habe ich mich dann auch dazu
hinreißen lassen aus eigenem geld aus
mitteln die mir außenwelt zur verfügung
standen diesem modell betrieb zu
finanzieren
[Musik]
macht im kiez schaffen auch die hells
angels modelle laufhäuser bars
diskotheken fast überall haben die
rocker das sagen ja nie beteiligt die
höllenengel auch an seinem club er
verspricht sich dadurch mehr einfluss
und schutz
ich habe mir damals durch den verkauf
der anteile im tropicana folgendes
versprochen
und zwar erstmal eine partnerschaft die
mich in höhere kreise einführt der
organisierten kriminalität wir wollten
damit natürlich dann auch den goldenen
wurf landen
daraufhin habe ich natürlich dann auch
dementsprechend prozent der abgegeben
und zwar 50 prozent damit er überhaupt
auch interesse entsteht weil mir ginge
es ja mit dem betreiben des tropicana es
nicht um geld
bei mir ging es einfach darum den fuß in
die szene zu kriegen auf einer höheren
ebene
doch das geschäft mit den hells angels
platz die rocker steigen vorzeitig aus
durch das ausscheiden meiner
eigentlichen partner mussten die
ausbezahlt werden ich hatte damals nicht
die finanziellen mittel um das jetzt mal
eben zu machen wir sprechen ja über eine
summe von
50.000 euro und mehr eines tages stand
ein junger versicherungsmakler bei mir
im laden der die bücher einsehen wollte
und es stellte sich heraus dass er wohl
von einem sehr bekannten gewalttäter aus
dem hamburger rotlicht milieu von meinem
laden angeboten bekommen hatte die eher
teuer bezahlte das geld aber wohl nie
angekommen war
normalerweise hätte der hells angel
damit bezahlt werden müssen das ist aber
wohl nicht geschehen dass nur ein
bruchteil von dem geld angekommen und
somit stellte sich dann heraus dass
dieser junge versicherungsmakler nach
kitzen männern betrogen worden war
bei dem vermeintlichen club ermittler
handelt es sich um den stadtbekannten
gewalttäter marcel m
auch bekannt als knochenbrecher masse
seine betrügerische aktion mit dem
versicherungsmakler macht ja nie in der
szene öffentlich er provoziert entdeckt
die gegenreaktion folgt die polizei geht
von einer auftrag schlägerei aus
die angreifer konnten hier vorne
der anbau war mein büro
da hat sich damals die schießerei
ereignet die angreifer sind hier über
den eingangsbereich trüben
zum laden haben geklingelt sind
reingelassen worden und haben dann mit
vier personen das büro gestürmt und
haben da das feuer auf mich eröffnet
es gab eine auseinandersetzung in der
folge man hat dann die täter aus dem
büro rausgedrückt offensichtlich dabei
gab es die schussabgabe in die decke
verletzt wurde keiner
man hat dann die tür zu drücken können
und durch die geschlossene tür ist dann
noch mal geschossen wurden wo ich dann
hinter noch den schuss ins knie abwehren
konnte und die angreifer sind geflüchtet
der tropicana chef kommt verletzt ins
krankenhaus
die angreifer stellen sich wenige tage
später bei der polizei
der überfall ist für jenny ein weckruf
der wird noch vorsichtiger doch sein
leben ist weiterhin in akuter gefahr
ich habe grundsätzlich eine 9mm dabei
gehabt die hatte ich meistens am körper
versteckt ich hätte zu hause eine waffe
grundsätzlich immer im schlafzimmer und
ich habe natürlich woche gemäss ich die
autos gewechselt ich habe unter die
autos geschaut wenn irgendwas war ob da
irgendwelche bomben oder zeitzünder oder
irgendwelche bremsleitungen manipuliert
waren also ich war immer gewarnt und auf
strom
[Musik]
sein gefühl täuscht ihm nicht der
nächste feind lauert bereits in der
stadt
ein albanischer auftragskiller getarnt
als italienischer zuhälter hat es auf
jenny abgesehen
in diesem geschäft das früher einmal ein
internet café bar treffen sich die
beiden zum ersten mal
johnny ist von anfang an misstrauisch
willigt aber ein dem fremden besucher
hamburg zu zeigen
[Musik]
damals als ich besuch vom killer hatte
der in meinem auto saß und ich an einer
tankstelle in hamburg betankt hatte ist
mir aufgefallen dass er mit einem tuch
so ähnlich wie diesem hier über die
armaturen strich erwischte überall da wo
er angefasst hatte wischte er die
armaturen sauber um seine spuren zu
verwischen und das kam er doch damals
sehr verdächtig vor
da wurde ich damals auch hellhörig und
war dann auch gewarnt
[Musik]
die lk leute sagen dass damals genauso
wie ich da muss wohl was im busch sein
der vorteil damals war dadurch dass er
dachte dass wir eventuell noch
weiterfahren hatte er sein gepäck bei
mir im wagen vergessen seine tasche
nicht nur die ganzen wegwerfen dies
waren in dieser tasche zu finden auch
ein komplett neues outfit und eine
plastiktüte mit einem nassen tuch was
mit wasserstoffperoxid behandelt worden
war
was als bleichmittel und destruktion
mittel eingesetzt wird
ich gehe davon aus dass er vorhatte mich
zuhause zu töten
jenny schmiedet gemeinsam mit dem lka
einen plan sie wollen unbedingt an die
personalien des albaners kommt dafür
täuschen sie vor seinem hotel eine
polizeikontrolle vor die aktion glückt
aber die beamten können den verdächtigen
mann nicht verhaften und müssen ihn
laufen lässt
ein paar tage später bekommt ja nie an
der überraschende nachricht gegen abend
habe ich dann einmal anruf bekommen dass
meine vermutung wohl richtig gewesen ist
dass der bereits in der verhandlung war
wegen anderen tötungsdelikten und
international gesucht wurde
mir ist bekannt dass er wohl zwei oder
drei tage später an einer europäischen
grenze festgenommen werden konnte und
wurde dann zum verhör nach hamburg
verbracht letzten endes haben die
ereignisse in hamburg unter anderem auch
die begegnung mit meinem auftragskiller
war mit meinem keller haben letzten
endes auch dazu geführt dass ich in
nordrhein-westfalen mich für den
nächsten einsatz gemeldet habe und
rocker geworden bin
[Musik]
damals zu einer freiheitsstrafe von
sechs jahren verurteilt worden
die haben dadurch rund wenigen sales
gemacht ist genannt wird und finden
der brandanschlag erfolgte auf dem
grundstück meiner familie
[Musik]